wir stehen vor einer bitteren bilanz so
bundespräsident steinmeier über die
russlandpolitik deutschlands in den
letzten jahren die unter anderem er als
außenminister und die kanzler schröder
und merkel verantwortet haben russland
sollte partner sein darauf waren die
beziehungen ausgerichtet in der hoffnung
den frieden in europa zu bewahren eine
fatale fehleinschätzung das wissen wir
heute und wir müssen sehr viel
wehrhafter sein so die
bundesverteidigungsministerium heute im
bundestag ja wie sieht sie nun aus die
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende welche
konsequenzen hat das für uns auch
wirtschaftlich und helfen wir damit der
ukraine bittere bilanz was ändert sich
in der deutschen außenpolitik unser
thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
guten abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
berlin ich darf meine gäste vorstellen
natalia fiebrig ist bei ist und sie ist
journalistin mit
deutschlandkorrespondent des
ukrainischen tv-senders 1+1 und herzlich
willkommen erich vater ehemaliger
general und langjähriger militärberater
von bundeskanzlerin angela merkel heute
inhaber einer beratungsfirma
zugeschaltet ist als professor rüdiger
bachmann er ist deutsch amerikanische
wirtschaftswissenschaftler der
university of notre dame das ist ein
indianer in den vereinigten staaten
scheinen guten abend und ralf stegner
begrüße ich von der spd mitglied des
auswärtigen ausschusses und von 2014 bis
2019 war auch stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender um mit ihnen würde
ich auch gern beginnen herr stegner wenn
wir das jetzt gehört haben die reaktion
des bundespräsidenten ja dass die bilanz
bitter ist dass man es alles einfach
nicht richtig eingeschätzt hat würden
sie diese bittere bilanz der
russland-politik aufziehen
naja jedenfalls dass es eine zeitenwende
ist wenn das größte land in europa das
zweitgrößte überfällt und einen
aggressiven angriffskrieg führt das ist
schon so und ich glaube es war jetzt
nicht alles falsch aber in wesentlichen
teilen muss politik korrigiert werden
sie muss korrigiert werden bezogen auf
die eigene wehrhaftigkeit spricht
zustand der bundeswehr sie muss
korrigiert werden bezogen auf die
energieabhängigkeit
von russland
halt beides übrigens ja gemeinsam mutig
der letzten jahre und sicherlich war die
hoffnung auf zu optimistisch dass putin
sein land politisch ökonomischen
moralisch ruinieren will
keineswegs falsch war nach meiner
einschätzung
keineswegs falsch haben wir meines
erachtens
waren die bemühungen um diplomatie um
rüstungskontrolle um friedenspolitik und
natürlich auch darum dass man versucht
über wirtschaftliche beziehungen über
wissenschaftliche zusammenarbeit in
anderen feldern zu erreichen dass man
sich jedenfalls nicht feindselig
gegenübersteht weil natürlich russland
auch ein teil der sicherheit in europa
ist
landmann wird gegen lausanne kommen
sicher erreichen können das war nicht
falsch der gedanke und deswegen glaube
ich muss man sich auch hüten die falsche
schuss forderungen herauszuziehen um
putin hätte gewonnen wenn wir unser
denken komplett und unser handeln
militarisieren müssen wir aber
wahrscheinlich erfahrt was wie kommt
diese falsche einschätzung von russland
sie haben lange die kanzlerin beraten
auch immer mit der idee russland ist
unser partner was stand dahinter naja
die grundidee war was ja schon sagt ihr
nicht in der vergangenheit dass man da
und wollte dass russland anteil der
europäischen friedensordnung ist und
bleibt gleich und ich muss sagen das ist
auch eine forderung die in die zukunft
weist denn ich meine auch irgendwann ist
dieser krieg zu ende und irgendwann wird
man ob man will oder nicht auch mit
putin wieder reden müssen und irgendwann
wird will nachdenken wie gehen wir
weiter mit ihm um man kann ja nicht
einen ostwall aufziehen der nato um das
land ostwärts davon als niemandsland
ansehen das wird nicht gehen also
irgendwann muss man damit
ist jetzt natürlich ein anderes sie die
nato stärkt ihre ihre
abschreckungspotenzial gegenüber
russland sie trifft vorkehrungen dass
putin nicht appetit auf mehr bekommt
moldau ist ja nur ein thema die
baltischen staaten und polen liegen die
nerven blank berechtigt aus historischen
gründen auch das baltikum ist auch
schlecht zu verteidigen ich also man
muss ja über land über das land kommt
man kaum hinten sondern luft und seewege
nutzen die verbände die wir da
aufgestellt haben diese multi nationalen
verbände sind keine bedrohung für
russland
sie sind militärisch gesehen nicht viel
aber sie sind besser als gar nicht wenn
ich das jetzt so höre dann ist das eine
militärs strategische analyse wie passt
das zusammen zu den bilder wenn sie das
so hören frau fiebrig wir haben alle die
bilder von butter im kopf her sind
einfach noch irgendwie eigentlich fast
gelähmt von diesem entsetzen und diesem
grauen und wenn jetzt herr fahrt sagt
wir müssen gucken wie wir dann auch
irgendwann mal wieder mit putin uns
zusammenfinden wie wirkt das auf sie das
ist schon ziemlich schwierig ich muss
zugeben ich bin selbst absolut geschockt
von diesen bildern obwohl mich diese
grausame
diese grausamen taten
naja vielleicht nicht so überraschend
weil es schon vor dem krieg hat auch die
amerikanische aufklärung gewarnt dass
die russische militär auch so
eliminierung stylisten hatte also
überall wo man dann in wir reingehen
würde hätte man dann eine liste von
personen die zu eliminieren sind und das
nicht nur politische klasse sondern auch
kulturschaffende aktivisten ja und ganz
ganz viele ideen träger die eigentlich
die
moderne ukraine ausmachen und russland
möchte jetzt die ukraine einfach
auslöschen das sagte auch er sagt auch
der präsident putin ganz offen und in
dieser situation
würde ich schon
darüber gedanken machen wie man sich vor
diesem großen russland schützt und nicht
mit ihrer forderung was der punkt wo sie
sagen dass erwarten sie jetzt eigentlich
gerade von deutschland ich hoffe dass
man auch in deutschland irgendwie dazu
kommt dass die notwendigkeit ist
russland und putin da zu stoppen wohl
gerade ist und nicht irgendwie weiter
ziehen lassen weil das es hier schon
eine lange reihe von aktionen die wir
schon viele gehabt hatten mit georgien
krieg mit lektion von creme mit
errichtung von separatistischen
republiken und jetzt diese absolut
grausamer krieg gegen die ukraine diese
dieses vernichtungskrieg das muss ja
gestoppt werden das kann ja nicht
einfach so geduldet werden und gesagt
hier aber irgendwie müssen wir dann mit
russland weiter leben müssen und viele
diskussionen gehen eben genau darum ob
man ihnen ob man es mit wirtschaftlichen
mitteln stoppen kann herr bachmann sie
haben eine studie mit anderen kollegen
vorgelegt wo sie gesagt haben ja wir
könnten das man könnte sich das auch
wirtschaftlich erlauben ein embargo
gegen gas wäre das ihrer meinung nach
wirklich ein instrument um diesen krieg
zu beenden
na ja also wir haben ja nachdem wir uns
als westen entschieden haben militärisch
also selber nicht aktiv in der ukraine
zu intervenieren haben wir im grunde
genommen ja nur zweimal
die waffenlieferungen von dessen ziehen
und möglicherweise auch immer offensiv
werden wer denn deren waffen an die
ukraine das ist nicht mal eine expertise
des militärs und strategen
militärstrategen entscheiden ob das eine
gute strategie und dann gibt es eben so
zu sagen denn die wirtschaftliche seite
sozusagen den wirtschaftskrieg indem wir
uns ja im grunde genommen durch die
sanktionen die ja schon die ja schon
verhängt wurden befinden und dann ist
eben die frage erreichen diese
sanktionen aus da kann man inzwischen
als auch jedenfalls reichen die aus um
putin so zu schwächen dass er auch auf
dem schlachtfeld vielleicht probleme
bekommen wird da kann man muss man wohl
sagen das ist nicht der fall als erste
zwischenbilanz und wir haben uns in der
studie zunächst mal gar keine empfehlung
abgegeben sondern wir haben uns in
dieser studie zunächst einmal die frage
gestellt
stimmen eigentlich die vorhersagen die
dann es wurde ja schon lange über ein
total embargo nachgedacht stimmen
eigentlich denn die vorhersagen die so
manche befürchtet hatten dass es sich
dann um massenarbeitslosigkeit
massenarmut soziale
unruhen handeln würde und inzwischen
muss man nicht nur unsere studie nehmen
unsere war eigentlich gesagt sogar die
zweite die herausgebrochen ist es gab
eine vom institut für weltwirtschaft in
kiel die wurde aber irgendwie nicht so
beachtet dann kam unsere studie und dann
sind gott sei dank noch sehr viele
andere institute wissenschaftlergruppen
die sich das von ganz unterschiedlichen
seiten angeschaut haben und sind alle
eigentlich zum ergebnis gekommen dass im
schlimmsten fall in der tat eine massive
rezession droht wenn wir das machen
sollten also vor allen dingen weil wir
ein totales gas-embargo machen öl und
kohle ist weniger problematisch und
dass das war eine schwere rezession wird
aber keine rezession die wir nicht mit
gute wirtschaftspolitik
managen können herr stegner wenn sie das
hör marcel bachmann da sagt ihr
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat ja vor
einiger zeit ganz klar gesagt das sehen
die wissenschaftler falsch hat das
zurückgewiesen was würden sie sagen
nachbarn jetzt ist es die moralische
pflicht zu sagen wir müssen wir brauchen
dieses embargo egal was ist
wirtschaftlich für auswirkungen hat
finde ich muss man die dinge richtig
einordnen das schlimmste das was die
bevölkerung zu ertragen hat in der
ukraine dass menschen getötet werden
verletzt werden angst kälte hunger
vertreibung flucht
terror als junger soldaten sterben
müssen die sich auch was anderes
vorgestellt haben das ist finde ich das
wichtigste und deswegen den krieg so
schnell wie möglich zu beenden und für
humanitäre hilfe song hat für mich
vorrang gegenüber allen anderen
überlegungen dass wir die zur einordnung
sachen damit das nicht missverstanden
wird die sanktionen ob diese wirkungslos
sind da braucht man das eben beschrieben
hat das weiß ich nicht es sind die
schärfsten die es bisher gegeben hat die
wir sind über das auch einvernehmlich
vereinbart worden mit den verbündeten
und manche kommen ja auch heißt zur
wirkung ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch
man mit rechenmodellen am ende
nachvollziehen kann was passiert wenn
wir unsere industriegesellschaft was
jetzt an geht von einem auf den anderen
tag auf null bringen dass wir natürlich
raus müssen aus der abhängigkeit so
schnell wie möglich das ist keine frage
als total ja auch um den preis dass wir
uns mit partnern einlassen die kaum
weniger blutrünstig cent wenn ich mir
manches arabische regime so angucke aber
das sei nur anders an der seite bemerkt
aber wir hören von der industrie mit dem
wir natürlich auch reden dass wenn
wenn das gast sozusagen auch 0 dinge
sofort dass die verwerfung die das zur
folge hätte in den lieferketten in den
produktionsprozessen
nicht mal so eben ausgeglichen werden
können und es kann ja nicht die fahrer
sein dass deutschland keine nachteile in
kauf nimmt das tun wir wir sind nicht
nur diejenigen die nur eine material am
stärksten unterstützt haben wir liefern
inzwischen auch waffen was sich in
teilen jedenfalls auch skeptisch sehe
und wir fragen auch ein großteil der
sanktionen war soll die am ende mehr
platzieren ganzen sanktionen und selbst
härter treffen als russlands ja ich
wollte ganz gern und das ist der punkt
über den man nachdenken muss aber kurze
nachfrage warum was sehen sie skeptisch
und den waffenlieferungen
ich verstehe das argument dass natürlich
die ukraine sich selbst verteidigen
können müssen ich habe auch eine
situation verschiedenes großvaters zu
tun ich glaube nur dass die these die es
gab mit waffen die frau würde man den
krieg am schnellsten beenden dass das
nicht der fall ist sondern im gegenteil
alle prognosen dich jetzt hörer gehen
darauf hinaus dass der krieg sich
deutlich verlängert und das bedeutet ja
dass zerstörung weitergibt geht dass
menschen sterben in der ukraine
dass kinder traumatisiert werden dass
dieses ganze elend sagt es gibt nichts
schlimmeres als krieg das heißt nicht
dass ich möchte dass dann satelliten
regime gibt das ich halte es nicht dass
ich sage wir hatten zu entscheiden was
die ukraine tut das ist ein
selbstständiger chancen die selbst tun
aber so wenig wie wir die nato
involvieren in den krieg und das dürfen
wir aus ganz anderen konnten nicht tun
weil das weltkriegs gefahren aus ich
glaube dass umgehen ich hab mich das
argument dass immer mehr und immer
offensiver waffen dazu führen dass wir
schneller zum kriegsende kommen der
nicht mit der meinung sich ein
moralisches dilemma da würde ich gerne
noch kann ich noch zwei sachen glas
herrmann ich würde ganz gerne mal einmal
kurz nach den gewinnen der den
ehemaligen general dazu hören inwieweit
würden weiteren waffen und welche waffen
helfen diesen krieg zu stoppen
die waffen die wir jetzt liefern helfen
den ukrainern sich selbst zu verteidigen
und
und zwar in dem bereich in denen sie
auch waffen brauchen nicht also das sind
vor allen dingen boden-luft-raketen da
sind panzerabwehrwaffen das sind
handfeuerwaffen panzerfäuste das ist das
was deutschland auch tut und das ist für
das jetzt sicher das glaube ich nicht
ich denke mal die waffen die sie
bekommen ich meine es ist eine
größenordnung die amerikaner bis zu
einer milliarde die eu wird auch in
richtung einer milliarde gehen und die
volumina sind schon erheblich und wir
wollen ja das ist die politische
grundlinien nicht so kriegspartei werden
das ist linie der nato aller 30
nato-mitgliedsstaaten und man ist
natürlich als waffenlieferant auf einer
schiene in richtung kriegspartei das
muss man einfach sehen und da muss man
schon
dosiert vorgehen und das kann man nicht
einfach ausufern lassen wenn man das
nicht will am ende in einen krieg
hineinschlittern der dann mit sicherheit
ein weltkrieg ist russland ist nicht
serbien russland ist auch nicht
afghanistan oder irak oder syrien oder
libyen russland ist eine nuklearmacht
mit den weltweit meisten nuklearen
sprengsätzen und wie man von putin ja
auch gehört hat sind sie bereit die auch
einzusetzen das hat eine andere qualität
und dann muss man einfach anders mit
umgehen könnte man aber auch sagen weil
man schnell viele waffen liefern würde
dann könnte man vielleicht diesen krieg
schneller stoppen dass er dann auch
denke ja das problem ist jetzt bei
diesen ganzen kriegen die dieser
konventionelle teil scheint ja zu ende
zu sein es scheint jetzt tatsächlich wir
stehen in eine verlängerung zu gehen in
vielleicht eine never ending story der
krieg ist noch nicht entschieden aber
natürlich die verlängerung des krieges
ist für die russische seite
hochproblematisch militärisch betrachtet
und für den verteidiger an für die
ukraine von vorteil aber bringt
natürlich unendlich ist laut mit für die
zivilbevölkerung die ganzen kriege die
wir hatten irak afghanistan
hatten hunderttausende von zivilen toten
es gab also so schlimm das ist was wir
jetzt neulich gesehen haben das ist
quantitativ ein bruchteil dessen was zum
beispiel beim irak-krieg zu verzeichnen
war unser zivil tun wir hatten auch in
afghanistan
tausende hunderttausende von 70 toten
wir hatten auch listen der nato mit
bestimmten leuten die wir im eliminiert
haben mussten und das auch gemacht haben
das würde deutschland hat da nicht
mitgemacht aber es wurde gefahren das
ganze und diese kriege sind leider so
wie sie sind und deswegen ist für mich
auch der der ansatz ebenda dass man
versuchen sollte so weit so schnell wie
möglich aus diesem aus dieser
militärischen eskalation hinauszukommen
in richtung politischer verhandlungen
das ist wirklich auch mein fröhliche
glauben sie dass das noch funktionieren
kann gerade jetzt auch nach diesen
letzten ereignissen dass man sagt ja man
sehen sie noch eine hoffnung auf
verhandlungen oder ist es eher dass man
sagt wir brauchen einfach so viele
waffen wie möglich und wir müssen das
militärische müssen es eben gewinnen
gegen putin
es ist schon etwas traurig wenn uns in
deutschland nahe gelegt wird die ukraine
soll möglichst schnell kapitulieren und
dann gibt es diesen krieg nicht dann
gibt es einfach in frieden
liegt ihnen das nahe dass das höre ich
dass das höre ich bei herrn stegner das
höre ich auch von herrn vater
das habe ich ja wirklich nicht getan
nämlich dass bitte sagen wer das möchte
verstehen das und das habe ich wirklich
nicht getan denn das hat die ukraine
selbst zu entscheiden wir haben zu
verantworten wie wir am besten helfen
kann und mir geht es um die
zivilbevölkerung um die opfer dar und
das ist ein moralisches dilemma ich
verstehe das sehr gut aber ich lege
keineswegs so carina aufzugeben dass wir
völlig fern dinge selbst zu entscheiden
ich teile aber das was eben gesagt
worden ist von einfahrt wir müssen zu
einem waffenruhe com und dazu dass dann
eben kein satelliten regime entstehen
kann aber am ende hat die ukraine das zu
verantworten wir müssen helfen so gut
wir können ob die hilfe darin bestehen
den weg zu verlängern da habe ich meine
zweifel und kriege sind über das immer
das schlimmste und furchtbar sie richten
sich nie gegen militärische ziele
premiere weil es immer die
zivilbevölkerung die dass die da zu
leiden hat und das ist grausam und
furchtbar und um einen menschen geht es
mir auch nicht da haben wir einiges
fortzuschreiben ja gut dann habe ich sie
falsch verstanden
aber das ist oft
auf diesen diskurs was uns gesagt wird
wir brauchen einfach einen frieden aber
was heißt denn frieden also ich glaube
und ganz viele meiner landsleute glauben
wir brauchen den ukrainischen sieg weil
was gibt es denn ansonsten
und eigentlich in russland wird das
ziemlich offen kommuniziert und putin
sagt dass auch relativ offen wenn man
aufmerksam zuhört und auch in den
letzten jahren zugehört hat dann weiß
man ziemlich genau was russland der
ukraine
vor hartz und ich empfehle die lektüre
eine artikel die jetzt vor kurzem bei
der russischen staatsagentur ria nowosti
erschien ist wo es darum geht was
russland mit der ukraine zu tun hat und
da geht es fragte schon die endlösung
der ukrainischen frage also es geht
darum dass die ukraine als staat
ausgelöst werden muss es geht
keinesfalls nur um militär es geht um
breite schichten der ukrainischen
bevölkerung soll die russische das
russische militär gar nicht
unterscheiden zwischen den streitkräften
und diejenigen die nicht zum militär
gehören sollen die ukraine sozusagen zu
rosen
umerzogen werden sollen
konzentrationslager und wie
funktionieren die werden als
entnazifizierung stellen genannt die 25
jahre irgendwie funktionieren sollen die
die ukraine dann auf ganz verschiedenen
ebenen auf kultureller ebene auf
pädagogische ebene umerziehen sollen und
das ist dann eben die frage
wenn wir danach geben und wenn wir
russland ermöglichen der ukrainische
präsident sagt über völkermord besagt
über genozid ist es dann zu verkraften
auch für deutschland und ist es auch in
sicherheitsinteressen von deutschland
wenn man sozusagen an der grenze sollen
regime hat wie stark herr bachmann
müssen diese moralischen ja die
moralische pflicht wie stark wie kddi
wenn man wirtschaftliche entscheidungen
trifft
das muss letztlich
die politik entscheiden das kann ich als
ökonom
den politikern nicht abnehmen aber ich
bin ja nicht nur ökonomen sondern auch
bürger und ich bin jemand der
geschichte kennt und ich weiß das geht
ja nicht nur um die reine ich hatte es
ja für die ukraine zur zeit geschildert
aber es geht ja um viel mehr
als jemand der sich mit geschichte
beschäftigt weiß man doch wie das
russische reich in grenzen von 1917
ausgesehen hat und da will putin hält
das hat er uns ja allen gesagt also ich
finde man sollte ich werde einfach dass
wir den man einfach mal zuzuhören was er
eigentlich genau will und das kann sein
dass er jetzt zu schwach zu ist das
umzusetzen aber das ist doch
offensichtlich seien langfristiges ziel
aber wenn ich darf ich möchte noch etwas
zu einer sagen ich bin doch etwas
verwundert wenn er hier mathematische
modelle kritisiert wir müssen ohne
mathematische modelle nichts über den
klimawandel wir wissen nichts über die
epidemiologie während der korona krise
und wir benutzen natürlich auch in der
ökonomie immer wieder mathematische
modelle die politik benutzt unsere
mathematische modelle um
steuerschätzungen zu machen jetzt steht
er also sein dass er sich hier gegen
mathematische modelle und damit
letztlich wissenschaft ausspricht finde
ich doch sehr verwunderlich und besser
dann unsere späße kritisiert dann bitte
ich doch darum auch als auch mal zu
gucken und genau dieses szenario zu
diskutieren dass wir da untersucht haben
und es ist einfach falsch zu behaupten
dass wir als es darum ging es am morgen
um ein gasstopp aus russland geht also
das genannt worden dass dann kein gas
mehr vorhanden werden denn wir gehen ja
in die sommermonate und das was wir am
gas brauchen über die sommermonate da
besteht eigentlich einigkeit rennt da
braucht man das russische gas eigentlich
nicht das gas aus norwegen und anderen
fällen kommt reicht über die
sommermonate wieder das russische gas
brauchen ist für den zu die heizung und
die wärme im winter da zusätzlich haben
wir ja wir haben uns für die industrie
natürlich auch ja aber über den sommer
unter dem bereich oder sogar
entschädigung ist wie das wollte ich nur
sagen na ja im moment an dem punkt muss
ich jetzt noch machen das heißt wir
reden hier über ein szenario dass es zu
engpässen kommen wird in sechs sieben
monaten nicht heute das heißt wir haben
jetzt noch zeit entsprechende
anpassungen zu fahren also so zu tun
dass wir uns international geräten da wo
morgen überhaupt kein gas mehr ist was
ist einfach denn ich würde gern noch
anschließen
hermann gerne position kann man kann die
portionen können
man kann die opposition kritisieren weil
man sie falsch findet aber man sollte
sie nicht garantieren ich habe nicht
gesagt dass ich nichts von
mathematischen modellen halte dir sind
selbstverständlich nötig und ich habe
auch nichts gegen wissenschaft ganz im
gegenteil ich habe lediglich gesagt
präzise formuliert dass ich das für
unzureichend halten um das zu
beschreiben was wir an die verketten
haben eine verknüpfung prozessen in der
deutschen industrie das lässt sich
glaube ich nicht alles berechnen und wir
reden ja mit den leuten die dafür
zuständig sind und die gefahr dass das
so zu sagen dann verschiedene oder
lähmungen fragen müssen dann wissen wir
bei uns dichtmachen interessen haben in
der industrie ein großteil der energie
verbrauchen wir in der industrie das
muss man ernst nehmen und das muss man
jedenfalls prüfen dass sie so schnell
wie möglich raus mit ist keine frage
aber das mit dem sofortigen lieferstopp
aus moralischen gründen wenn das am ende
das land stärker bestraft dass das tun
soll als das land gegen der sich diese
aktionen richten oder gar nichts bewirkt
dann ist das keine kluge politik und die
emotionen sind das eine und die teile
ich wirklich alle aber der kluge kopf
und der kühle kopf dass man das was wir
antwort weiß aufmacht in verantwortung
über der eigenen bevölkerung das gehört
auch dazu ja ich will
das anders gesehen wird aber ich würde
bitten das nicht zu karikieren der ifo-
präsident clemens fuß der hat gemeint es
sei sinnvoll gasimporte aus russland
sofort einzustellen das wäre sinnvoll
denn nach dem ende des ukraine krieg sei
es klüger wieder gas aus russland zu
importieren sowohl wegen der kosten der
energieversorgung als auch strategisch
weil es sei auch nicht hilfreich wenn
wir als deutschland uns wirtschaftlich
so schwächen der vaart ich würde gern
noch mal darauf schauen wenn man
nochmals eben zurückschaut wenn man
sieht warum ist das eigentlich ja warum
war diese fehleinschätzung so haben wir
haben versucht russland als partner
einzubinden
das war aber nach der krise nach der
krise an aktion 2014 war doch eigentlich
klar das kann so nicht funktionieren
angela merkel war eigentlich gegen nord
stream hat es aber nicht durchgesetzt
sie haben sie lange beraten also was
warum die außenpolitik so wie sie
gelaufen na ja nun wahrlich nicht der
wirtschaftsberater aber es war trotzdem
ich meine damals 14 reaktionen sie hat
ja damals diese beiden minsker abkommen
auch ausgehandelt und ich meine sie war
die einzige westliche
regierungschefin letztlich mit der putin
ernsthaft geredet hat und das ging ja
über einen längeren zeitraum das war ja
auch wieder ein versuch
natürlich
diese diese diese völkerrechtswidrige
aktion der russen irgendwo wieder in
politische kreise zu bringen und
einzufangen das ist lässt sich aus
heutiger sicht gescheitert das kann man
ihnen nicht zum vorwurf machen ich meine
es war damals geboten und einer der
möglichen wege da rauszukommen und er
ist gescheitert mit dem überfall auf die
ukraine aber dieser überfall war auch
absehbar er hat ja dass budapest am
rande umgebrochen nicht und die beiden
garantie mächte usa und großbritannien
dass das war absehbar schon im herbst
letzten jahres das vor einer eskalation
na ja wir haben in deutschland die
regierungsbildung nicht wer das ist ja
von putin auch mit im kalkül gewesen
nicht werden die wahlen in frankreich wo
man heute nicht weiß ob vielleicht
leprechaun zum zuge kommt das kann ja
auch ein erdrutsch sein und so einfach
deswegen bin ich bei modellrechnungen
aus der wirtschaft wenn man sie eins zu
eins überträgt mit diesen hohen kosten
für die bevölkerung teilweise spielen ja
auch irrationale faktoren dabei mit und
die franzosen entdecken ja zum teil
leider auch sowie wie die amerikaner die
vor nicht allzu langer zeit donald trump
gewählt haben dann haben wir dieses
problem den usa ja auch das muss man
schon sehen diese möglichen politischen
verwerfungen von wirtschaftspolitischen
entscheidungen heute die vielleicht gut
sind für den ukraine konflikt aber für
uns alle am ende negativer ich werde
auch ein bisschen vorsichtig finden sie
dass die kannst es gibt kritik daran
dass die kanzlerin sich noch nicht
persönlich geäußert hat zu diesem krieg
nachdem der bundespräsident hat sich
nach den ereignissen von bushehr
geäußert die kanzlerin hat das nicht
getan finden sie das richtig ich finde
dass ich meine sie hat 16 jahre hier
eines der schwierigsten jobs in
deutschland ausgeübt und das ist jetzt
auch gut so und jetzt das noch zu
kommentieren das ist auch nicht usus das
ist beim bundespräsidenten etwas anders
er ist ja noch im amt gleich er muss
stellung nehmen dazu aber ich finde das
finde ich absolut in ordnung dass sie
das nicht macht und dass sie sich da
raushält neulich hat er bis zum letzten
tag da ihre pflicht als regierungschefin
getan und ich weiß aus diesen 16 jahren
dass es ein hammerharter job ist nicht
und das sollte ihr erst mal einer
nachmachen frau fiebrig wie sehen sie es
präsident sie lenski hat ja gesagt
angela merkel soll nach butter kommen
und soll sehen was ihre politik
letztendlich angerichtet hat schon fahrt
auf und ganz viele meiner landsleute
fragen mich wo ist eigentlich angela
merkel gesagt sie war es und wie
reagiert darauf und man man erwartet
irgendwie ihre präsenz und da habe ich
eigentlich nicht nicht nicht viel zu
berichten also es gab zwei statements
frau merkel hat es sagen lassen
man hätte jetzt natürlich ziemlich viele
fragen
angela merkel war und ich habe wieder
ganz geschafft von anfang an verfolgt
sie hatte wirklich ein sehr großer
autorität in moskau wladimir putin
möglicherweise hätte sie diese dieser
autorität auch sehr gut einsetzen können
in der ukrainischen frage damit die
dieser krieg nicht
zustande käme
ist natürlich auch sehr interessantes
angela merkel gesagt hat die
entscheidung von 2008 den
weg der ukraine in die nato zurückkehren
war richtig dabei bleibt sie
bleibt sie dabei um das finde ich
ziemlich interessant weil ich glaube
dass war gerade das war damals ein
fehler nein aber richtig ich war dabei
bei dem nato gipfel als das letztlich
behandelt wurde auch entschieden wurde
zu dem zeitpunkt war es auch ein
massives innenpolitisches problem in der
ukraine also so die situation wie sie
heute da es ist war etwas anders gebe
ich zu aber damals war die ukraine
selbst auch sehr gespalten in dieser
frage das darf man nicht einfach abtun
es gab starke fraktionen die das auch
innerhalb der ukraine ich wollte und das
war auch mit ihrer begründung es ging
weniger um russland dabei und wenn sie
wenn wir das gemacht hätten hätte es
2008 schon diesen krieg geben denn im
falle georgiens haben sie das ja auch
gesehen im gleichen jahr hat putin ja
tatsächlich
südossetien abchasien besetzt mit
sogenannten friedenstruppen das ist ja
alles kurz nach dem nato-gipfel wie
gelaufen recht also so einfach ist das
nicht und es war eben auch der versuch
schärfe da raus zu nehmen
kriegs verhinderung zu machen ja im
nachhinein
kann man das kritisch sehen ich möchte
das nicht abtun aber zum damaligen
zeitpunkt eine politische entscheidungen
sind ja immer ereignis bezogen zeitraum
bezogen und das ist ja das nicht genau
das problem dass man eben nicht die die
längere strategie im kopf hat sondern
dass man da auf einen punkt schaut und
nicht ja man muss auch einen punkt auch
schauen jetzt deswegen ist für mich
wichtig dass wir jetzt schauen wie wir
aus dem konflikt heraus kommen und nicht
wie wir in eskalieren ich finde das
schon es ist schon brutal was putin
gemacht als das sind wir außerdem watte
und auch die art der kriegführung
natürlich nicht und ich was ich
bewundere ist diesen heroischen
widerstand der ukraine nicht da werden
auch zivilisten bewaffnet da wird man
geht man in den urbanen zentren zum
einem totalen widerstand des ganzen
volkes über aber ich weiß als militär
was das bedeutet es ist die blutigste
geschichte eines krieges überhaupt und
wenn sie für verlängerung sind ja wenn
sie wollen dass sich das perpetuiert
wird es tausende von toten gehen auch
unter der zivilbevölkerung und das kann
ich einfach nicht gut heißen deswegen
habe ich da ein problem obwohl ich
natürlich emotional auf ihrer seite bin
deutschland kann auch ziemlich viel aber
können sie dann guten gewissens sagen
man tut alles also das ist eine
interessante frage an wir tun alles was
möglich ist um einen dritten weltkrieg
zu verhindern das macht die ganze nato
und deutschland macht das merken aber
ich
würde gern den beiden die zu
schlechteren position sind herr stegner
wollte dir etwas sagen dann herr
bachmann dazu
der krieg ist durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen und putin ist ein
kriegsverbrecher der gehört in den
nachwuchs gericht gestellt das ist für
mich gar keine frage
trotzdem und muss als sozialdemokrat ja
von merkel nicht verteidigen aber ich
glaube nicht dass man sagen kann ihre
politik habe dass unser soziales
ergebnis gehabt das finde ich es ist man
kann ich habe geschichte studiert
politik wenn der gegenwart gemacht wird
hinterher interpretiert es war
gemeinsame politik zu versuchen
sympathie für den autokraten putin hat
den bundestag nur die afd die russische
position automatisch richtig finden hat
linkspartei wir waren der meinung
gemeinsame sicherheit geht indem man
versucht mit russland das diplomatisch
hinzu gegen das ist nicht gelungen das
macht das aber nicht falsch oder im
sinne von moralisch verwerflich dass man
dafür verantwortlich sei und deswegen
finde ich uns auch schwierig wenn die
deutsche opposition
herr merz zum beispiel jetzt die
verwicklung der spd in beziehung zu
russland oder suchen will und verkennt
dass wir das gemeinsam mit guten
absichten sozusagen in der regierung
gemacht haben auch mit dem metzger
abkommen das war ja ein guter absicht
damit verbunden das zu tun dass das
nicht funktioniert hat spricht jetzt
nicht dagegen dass der ansatz falsch und
im übrigen ist doch ein segen dass im
weißen haus momentan nicht als tramp
sitzt wüsste gar nicht wie die situation
jetzt aussehen haben das muss man ja
sehen wir haben immerhin jetzt eine
gemeinsame reaktion des westens was
putin über das überrascht hat diese
hirntote nato von der
makro gesprochen hat die da sind die
geräte wieder angestellt worden dies
putzmunter und reagiert gemeinsam und
europäische union ist handelt auch
gemeinsam was wir lange nicht hatten es
gibt schon auch ein ergebnis das der
putin sich in vielen verrechnet hat der
heroische widerstand keine götter auch
dazu trotzdem kann man das argument
teilen den krieg zu verlängern bedeutet
vor allen dingen leid für die
bevölkerung und das darf man auch im
blick haben wenn man politik macht finde
ich sehr respektiere herr bachmann
also ich finde ich finde gerade wegen
der amerikanischen gefahr und ich sitze
in amerika und die gefahren das mit 2024
wieder ein präsident trump oder einem
tram pisten im weißen haus haben werden
gerade da spricht dass wir den krieg
dass noch weitere argumente krieg
schnell aber eben entscheidend zu
beenden und eben nicht als satelliten
start und an frieden und russischer
herrschaft haben wir doch jetzt gesehen
wie der aussehen würde ich möchte aber
nochmals mit zwei finde ich mythen
aufräumen das erste ist wird nicht
anders das sieht man jetzt tun wir nicht
alles da sieht man schon deshalb weil
wir ja unsere sanktionen immer weiter
steigern das europäische parlament heute
gefordert oder darüber diskutiert was
man wirtschaftlich noch machen kann ob
wir militärisch schon alles tun dass es
nicht meine expertise noch mal
ökonomisch tun wir auf keinen fall alles
was denke ich für uns
verkraftbar wäre ich wehre mich auch
gegen diesen mythos den erfahrt ihr so
ein bisschen ebenfalls andeutet man
konnte das irgendwie nicht wissen also
erstens eben politisch darf man mal
darauf aufmerksam machen dass zum
beispiel frau berbalk schon länger aber
überhaupt die grünen schon länger davor
gewarnt haben was unsere
energieabhängigkeit
ja im grunde genommen eine kriegsgefahr
darstellt und genau so ist es gekommen
und da muss man auch ich bin
wissenschaftler leute die richtige
vorhersagen machen die haben zunächst
mal würde ich sagen einen ja einen
anschluss den sollte man mal vielleicht
in zukunft auch grauer zu hören übrigens
haben uns das und das ärgert mich halt
auch als jemand der von außen auf europa
guckt er von jemanden sehr
internationalen umfeld lebt der sehr
viel mit auch ost europäern zu tun hat
es ging immer nur um russland es wurde
eben nicht auf andere osteuropäer wie
die polen das konnte man so abtun das
ist so eine quasi trump regierung was
die polen sagt das buch das muss man
nicht so ernst leben glaube ich gibt es
und gab es uns sagen wir mal so ein
zungenschlag in berlin wir haben nicht
auf die ukraine gehört und das hat eben
leider leider leider von außen gesehen
eine lange ganz schlimm historische
tradition dass eben zwischen deutschland
und russland sozusagen beziehungen
hergestellt werden die länder
zwischendrin aber letztlich
das dann ausbaden müssen also das finde
ich gehört zur wahrheit auch dazu erst
wenn wir jetzt aber noch mal fragen was
muss sich ändern in der deutschen
außenpolitik wenn wir welche lehren
müssen wir ziehen etwas was wäre für sie
so einen punkt wo sie sagen also wir
sagen ja wir müssen wehrhafter werden
wir müssen die bundeswehr muss anders
aufgestellt oder ein also haben wir viel
zu lange auch das gedacht na ja wir
haben so die bundeswehr aber eigentlich
bekommt jedoch nicht zum einsatz ja ich
habe auch in der hinsicht einfach ich
glaube die wichtigste erkenntnis ist
dass gewalt und der einsatz von
militärischer macht weiterhin ein leider
ein instrument der außenpolitik
geblieben ist das ist ja aus dem
deutschen denken auch vielfach
ausgeblendet worden auch aus dem
deutschen politischen denken dass einer
mit gewalt an nachbarland einfach über
fällt das ist ja an dieser
paradigmenwechsel diese zeitenwende von
dem der bundeskanzler spricht einen
krieg in europa ist wieder möglich für
bahn überfall eben auch und das ist
schon etwas fundamental anderes und wir
müssen verstehen dass außenpolitik eben
mehr ist als runden
am runden tisch wo man sich dann bei
guten willen auch ein nicht sondern
wir handeln miteinander und dann sind
wir von bunten und dann wird das schon
okay sein ja gut aber wir sind eine
weltwirtschaftsmacht und wirtschaftliche
beziehungen sind eben wichtig noch was
mich nur gestört hat ist was wir als
einer der größten volkswirtschaften der
welt eine so kümmerliche armee haben ja
ich das passt nicht zusammen nicht wir
brauchen funktionsfähig streitkräfte das
ist jetzt auch klar geworden ich werde
ja vor fünf wochen noch ganz andere
themen und ich da war spielte
verteidigung überhaupt keine rolle und
wir haben jahrelang zugeschaut letztlich
muss ich auch sagen auch in den letzten
regierungen ich wir haben waren einfach
das interessiert wie die bundeswehr aus
sieht in welchem zustand de ist und das
hat sich jetzt geändert wo sie
persönlich auch sagen in dem wie sie es
eingeschätzt wenn sie jetzt wo sie sagen
ja da habe ich eigentlich auch fehler
ja vielleicht in dieser lange
afghanistan einsatz wir waren ja
fokussiert auf afghanistan in meiner
zeit im kanzleramt war das so und dann
bis vor kurzem noch und die
landesverteidigung spielt überhaupt
keine rolle wenn er einer gekommen wäre
wir müssen auch fit sein der anteile
hält man den tod ausgelacht weil ich das
vielleicht hätte man tatsächlich eher
rausgehen müssen als deutschland die
franzosen als 2011 gemacht wir haben es
auch erwogen aber dann haben wir gesagt
nein wir machen gemeinsam mit den
anderen partnern weiter wir wollen
gemeinsam rein gemeint raus alleine
sonderwege das ist dieses deutsche
dieser deutsche imperativ nie wieder ein
sonderweg gehen im ergebnis haben wir
mitgemacht bis zum gehtnichtmehr nicht
also hätte man vielleicht auch und dann
auch nach der krim an aktion ja mit dem
wissen von heute hätte man den hebel den
man heute umlegt vielleicht vor sieben
jahren schon umlegen können aber man hat
über das minsker abkommen versucht das
beste daraus zu machen das kann man
nicht alles schlecht reden heute und wie
stark dadurch sind die erwartungen in
nach auf nach deutschland gerichtet dass
deutschland ja da eine führungsrolle in
europa übernimmt und jetzt eben wirklich
hilft diesen krieg zu beenden dass die
initiative von deutschland auskommen
naja die erwartungen waren schon stark
aber jetzt mittlerweile wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr weil man sieht dass
deutschland tatsächlich eine
wirtschaftsstärkster land ist in der eu
aber irgendwie mit dieser politischen
situation doch etwas überfordert wir
hatten jetzt vor kurzem auch
verhandlungen friedensverhandlungen in
istanbul nicht in deutschland na und
dass das finde ich schade
gerade das ist ein großer unterschied zu
angela merkel also ich
wäre so dass von der leyen will ja nach
kiew reisen wäre es gut wenn scholz das
wäre ein sehr sehr gutes zeichen wenn
olaf scholz & friends hama cohen
zusammen nach die reisen würden ja das
würde schon ziemlich viel bedeuten
dass man wenn man jetzt sagt man muss
eine neue außenpolitik haben also wie
stark kann man auf die wirtschaft setzen
dass man sagt wir müssen miteinander ja
wir müssen diesen handel treiben wir
sind in einer globalisierten welt und
dadurch dass die besteht ja die hoffnung
dass sich dadurch auch dinge ende und
ist das nach wie ist das naiv oder kann
das funktionieren
es kann natürlich funktionieren das ist
zwar nicht immer falsch zu sagen hat
wandel durch handel aber ich glaube wir
müssen da auch unsere zunft glaube ich
tatsächlich noch mal neu nachdenken und
eben nicht alles sozusagen ein rein und
effizienz gesichtspunkten
ausrichten effizienz bedeutet eben
tatsächlich
immer zu sagen wo ist das billigste also
qualitätsbereinigte
das billigste und dann hat man eben eine
energiepolitik gemacht die hauptsächlich
das ist ja so dass gas das billigste gas
aus russland besorgt sich besorgt hat
hat aber eben und hat übrigens durch das
noch mal so sagen darf das hat so ein
bisschen für mich hatte so parallel zur
griechenland-krise da hat man nämlich
wenn man den griechen jahrelang eine
falsche fiskalpolitik vorgeworfen und
dann hat man gesagt als es dann
sozusagen zum schwur kam naja jetzt
müsst ihr das ausfahrten jetzt müsst ihr
dafür zahlen und so etwas erinnert mich
ein bisschen an unsere energiepolitik
die haben wir jahrelang gemacht und es
stellte sich heraus wir haben die
eigentlich auf kosten anderer gemacht
unter anderem jetzt der ukrainischen
zivilbevölkerung und deutschland ist
nicht bereit deutschland war sehr bereit
den griechen eine 20 prozent problemlos
produkt reduktion durch austerität
aufzudrücken wir sind aber nicht bereit
eine leichte rezession oder auch eine
mittelschwere rezession hinzunehmen dass
nochmals bei spielt also ich glaube wir
müssen sehr viel stärker nicht in
kategorien von effizienz sondern von
resilienz und strategien in der aktion
der denken und dann ist eben das
billigste produkt nicht langfristig
strategisch immer das beste herr stegner
ich sehe sie schütteln den kopf also
für die energiepolitik es gab gute
gründe für die energiepolitik
deutschland ist ein land mit der
steinkohle orientierung in der industrie
wollten raus ist der kohle raus aus atom
und dass das amerikanische gefragte gas
vorteil ist dass also ich finde das kann
man jetzt nicht vorhalten dass auch eine
gemeinsam betriebene energiepolitik die
energieabhängigkeit von russland ist ein
problem und sie muss korrigiert wenn das
habe ich ja gesagt aber das generell den
bogen zu verurteilen das finde ich
falsch
geschrieben deutschland tue zu kann
gehört sicherlich zu denjenigen die
militärischen kategorien zurückhaltender
formulieren als andere haben wir gute
gründe für deutschland hat im letzten
jahrhundert halb europa in schutt und
asche gelegt den holocaust verantworten
von toten in russland in der ukraine in
polen an dass wir also stärker auch den
diplomatischen teil den teils friedens
und rüstungskontrolle politik in den
vordergrund rücken und gegen uns das der
wehrhaftigkeit brauchen stimmt ich sein
darf stimmt auf und das mit der
bundeswehr übrigens hin glaube ich auch
damit zusammen dass sehr schnell die
wehrpflicht abgeschafft worden ist ohne
darüber nachzudenken was das heißt man
kann man nicht in der bundeswehr wo die
autos nicht fahren die flugzeuge nicht
fliegen die schiffe nicht seetauglich
sind wir keinen digitalfunk kam nicht
mehr auch nicht das geht nicht
stattdessen hatten ihr management
skandale beschaffungsskandale solche
dinge geld hat gar nicht so sehr gelegen
das muss korrigiert werden das werden
wir auch tun
ich würde das jetzt nicht so sagen dass
wir zu wenig tun wir sind zurückhaltend
in der öffentlichkeitsarbeit und wenn
man genauer hinguckt stellt nun soll was
die sanktionen angeht als auch was die
nachlieferung haben geht deutschland
keineswegs weniger tut also anders sein
im gegenteil auch mehr und im übrigen
muss ich auch sagen was er mit der
ukrainischen regierung offiziell und
was man öffentlich hört sind zwei völlig
verschiedene dinge
viel verständnis dafür dass das man das
aus emotionen heraus formuliert aber es
gibt sehr sehr gute beziehung und olaf
scholz telefoniert mit dem präsident
buchstäblich jeden tag und wir tun wir
was verantwortbaren vertretbar ist weil
wir natürlich wollen dass putin diesen
krieg nicht gewinnt und es darf kein
diktat das kann kein mensch wollen ja
stützen werden können da die frage wer
nämlich jetzt noch mal die frage auch
noch mal an sie herr fahrt was auf was
stellt man sich ein was denken sie wie
lange dieser krieg dauern wird naja ich
habe die befürchtung dass er sich in die
länge zieht das er monate dauern noch
noch monate dauern könnte und dass wir
dann eben dramatische entwicklungen
erleben werden das ist alles jetzt nur
das vorspiel ist nicht und deswegen das
vorspiel ist ja deswegen meine ich eben
dieser heroische widerstand der ukraine
ist wirklich lobenswert ich und
das was die russen gemacht haben ist
natürlich nicht in ordnung aber wir
müssen aus dieser eskalation einfach
raus nicht sonst
versumpfen wir in einem lang andauernden
krieg mit tausenden von toten wie wir es
exemplarisch erleben in syrien in libyen
in afghanistan hat sich auch im irak
nicht und da muss man irgendwie
hinkriegen und verhindern ich brauche
mich gibt's was worauf sie jetzt hoffen
konkret
ja und zwar ich hoffe dass
diese krieg militärisch gewonnen wird
das kann wirklich nur auf dem
schlachtfeld gewonnen werden das ist
dass es jetzt einfach zu spät über
invidis koalition zu reden wir haben
sehr lange darüber geredet es gab sehr
wohl auch diplomatische versuche die
ukraine hat alles mitgemacht als acht
jahre verhandelt wird für leider hat es
nicht
geholfen und jetzt wo es wirklich um
ermordeten zivilisten frauen kindern
geht wenn sie zu sagen ja wir müssen da
irgendwie raus und dann in wir versuchen
mit putin weiter ich glaube dass das
geht einfach nicht mehr vielen dank frau
fiebrig herr bachmann stegner und der
vaart war diese diskussion vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und ich würde sie gerne
aufmerksam machen auf unsere sendungen
morgen denn phoenix hat morgen
geburtstag werden 25 jahre alt und
morgen werden wir dazu auch in einer
etwas längeren besonderen phoenix runde
werden wir nämlich auch noch mal über
das thema krieg sprechen und über die
frage ja wahrheit oder lüge wer hat denn
die macht der bilder es freut mich sehr
wenn sie dabei sind morgen 22 15 phoenix
runde zum 25 geburtstag bis dann
[Musik]